I tell people my sister moved out west
your science teacher your husband he
renovate houses you're thinking about
moving but you're gonna waits until the
interest rates go down that's not my
story before I was an Avenger
I mean mistakes
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot of enemies
is callsigns taskmaster he controls the
Red Room there manipulated fully
conscious with no choices
I should have come back for you how did
the others are there enough
[Music]
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
we're family we fight with you
you won't win of course founded best
but look into the past
okay you got a plan or shall I just say
Duggan cut my plan was to drive us away
where your plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
between what the world wants you to be
who you are
and me my choice
I'm done running
[Music]
here's what's gonna happen Natasha don't
slouch
I'm not slouching you're going to get
the back hunched listen to mother oh my
god all right enough all of you I didn't
say anything that's not fair
you